résidences de tourisme 200 logements
nouveaux locaux pour le groupe scolaire
jean lurçat c'est le visage actuel du
quartier du pont du rotois à guyancourt
depuis 2006 l'entreprise eiffage travail
sur l'aménagement de ce terrain en
développant différentes infrastructures
il fallait que le projet soit adaptée
aux besoins de la ville de guyancourt et
c'est vrai que nous avons pas cherché à
valoriser à outrance ce foncier par
créer des escalopes de logements sur ce
site mais effectivement respectant les
choix la municipalité donc d'arriver à
conserver notamment de l'activité de
l'activité sera créé avec une clinique
de rééducation de 200 lits sa livraison
est prévue pour la fin de l'année 2016
avec à la clé environ 150 emplois pour
la ville ce qui était très important
c'était d'arriver à faire comprendre
qu'on avait une vision qu'on voulait
déséquilibre et après évidemment il a
fallu créer avec les phages les
conditions ça s'est fait par des
échanges de terrains et sa fille s'est
fait surtout dans le respect des
exigences de la ville en terme
d'aménagement cet été deux permis de
construire ont été déposés pour la
création d'une résidence
intergénérationnelle la réalisation d'un
espace commun au sein de cette résidence
et surtout donc la venue d'un opérateur
d'une association qui s'appelle
réciprocité qui permet effectivement de
fédérer autour même donc d'un animateur
au départ l'ensemble des habitants de
cet nouvel espace pour arriver à trouver
les activités commun de retrouver du
lien social
la livraison de ce projet devrait
intervenir courant 2018 pour conclure
plus de dix ans de réaménagement sur le
quartier du pont du rock thouars à
guyancourt